joining me today is an activist and
advocate who co-founded the student-led
gun control advocacy group never again
MSD he also helped organize the March
for our lives nationwide student
protests earlier this year cameron
Caskey welcome to the rubin report
thanks for having me I'm really happy
that you're here for for many reasons
mostly because you strike me suddenly as
someone that's trying to find some
common ground these days and we're gonna
get into that and a whole bunch more but
of course I have to mention up top you
are a survivor of the parkland shooting
in Florida before we go whole into that
and everything that you've been through
since just tell me a little bit about
life before because I assume you have a
life before and now a new life well you
know I spent most of my life as your
typical little shit-stirrer who just
said whatever you wanted to had a voice
I was always so convinced that I was
right about everything whether that was
nature or nurture is kind of up to
interpretation but I really grew up just
dead set on the fact that I knew
everything everything I said was right
and I was a genius I learned the hard
way recently little too recently that
I'm not and that was a crazy awakening
learning that you don't know everything
in the entire world is actually an
interesting experience but one of the
things that helped me a lot was doing
theater I was a big theater kid because
I had this voice I always wanted to
express myself I was you know I was
flippantly loud all the time and do I
didn't know what to do with it you know
I was knocking doors for Obama when I
was seven Wow yeah I was really
interested in you know being active with
all that I mean I knew nothing I thought
that John McCain was running with Tina
Fey not Sarah Palin because I really
only seen the news and I guess I got too
mixed up I was seven yeah I didn't
expect myself to be a policy expert but
you know again I think the point is I
was always really excited to to speak
and I got involved to drama and drama
said hey you have a voice here's a way
to use it and you learn a lot of lessons
from doing theater have you ever done
anything on stage that's cool not in
height
school I did spend 12 years doing
stand-up comedy in New York City which
is a whole other nightmare but I am I
always wanted to do stand-up and then I
tried it once when I was 7 years old I
was on a cruise with my family and there
was a kind of adults-only nightclub it
wasn't really the you were able to get
in if you were younger but I was the
only person there under maybe 40 and
they had an open mic and I kept on I
kept on raising my hand to get on him
but the host was saying know what that
was this kid doing good and finally he
just caved in I was like all right let's
let the kid get up here and and I walk
up there and I drop a 3-minute routine I
make a joke about my dad's penis which
was an interesting experience and the
thing is I did not know that while I was
sitting alone in the front row I snuck
out of my room my parents went to the
club and I didn't see them Wow so I'm
not there I'll say I'll send you the kid
the clip privately I'm out there and I'm
4 foot 3 and and everybody's drunk so
they think I'm a riot so I think I'm a
riot and I just kept going and going to
the point where though the guy who's
running the open mic was just looming
behind me waiting for me to be done but
I guess he just didn't want to grab the
mic from a small child without looking
kind of weird stand-up is probably best
done once at 7 years old and never again
so you're doing everybody's had their 15
minutes of fame when they were 7 on the
cruise yeah all right so so you were a
theater kid anything else we should know
about just like high school life like
high school life for a kid in 2017-2018
like what's it like I'm not that old but
I ain't 17 anymore well you know I high
school was really fun for me I really
enjoyed it on a social level I was a
shitty student my test scores were
always good but my grades were awful cuz
I never bothered to do homework I
thought I was too smart and cool for
that but um I liked high school a lot
because I I never really subscribed to
one social circle I kind of hung out
with a lot of people you know kids who
were the stereotypical popular kids you
know I was just the guy they knew that
was funny I would hang out with them
sometimes kids who were the
stereotypical Nerds we would talk about
movies and comic books which I want to
get into your comic book collection and
I'd say that my core group was the
theater kids okay I love my friends from
drama
and it's really fun having a group of
friends where you'll you'll be hanging
out in the weekend shooting the [ __ ] and
then you'll get to school and either be
falling in love with each other and
making out on stage or killing each
other on stage you know we just did
Fiddler on the Roof and I got to marry
one of my best friends I'm sure you're
familiar yeah yeah there I am familiar
with fiddler it's a classic yeah so all
right so it sounds like a pretty normal
childhood then so far I don't think
someone like me can be created by a
normal childhood but it was a great
childhood I'm very happy my parents
divorced when I was 10 and I'm lucky
enough to have four great parents you
know I've got two brothers and a
stepsister it's a great group well I'd
like to think that that I'm a pretty
moral guy and when I'm the shittiest
person in a family it's a great family
so I'm you have a stand-up comic in you
I can see it hopefully it doesn't come
out anytime soon all right so now bring
me to that day or later this year so on
February 14th there was a it was a
regular day it was actually a really
nice day and there was a period of time
during the day that I always remember
where I thought that he's going a little
too well hmm I was sitting reading John
Walsh's book tears of rage I believe a
familiar I don't remember the title
exactly but I was a big fan and um I was
planning out a Valentine's Day gift for
a girl that I really liked she had a she
had an endoscopy that day and she was up
she was on a lot of medicine and I was
going to give her cousin some gifts for
her and have her bring it to her and I
made her a card that said I would have
brought you this myself but I didn't
have the stomach for it right I predict
you are a crime I better hope sure of
her doctor and put it in the card and
everything and then I'm were in
rehearsal for a musical we were doing
Yale Vikings which I'm sure nobody's
ever heard of I don't know it and I was
we had just finished up a song and I was
doing and I realized wait a second I
have to go pick up my brother because
that stole my Douglas school lets out at
2:40 but the special-needs kids are out
at 2:10 so the parents can pick them up
before the buses come and my little
brother has autism and he's hanging out
there with all of his friends and the
ESC class and by the way the autistic
scene and Stoneman Douglas is awesome
those kids are the best and the school
specialized in that is it like a magnet
school for kids with autism or no but it
has a great program with great teachers
and I actually went back to parkland
this weekend to see them off to
homecoming and boy let me tell you that
squad is wild I love them and my little
brother I don't want to brag it's kind
of the ringleader over there and and I
went to go pick him up because on days
like that when my mom was at work I
would take him to drama and he would
just hang out and he really loved it
because all the girls would give him
attention yeah and you know he's he's a
bit of a cocky little bastard
and um and I realized it's maybe 220
let's say and I were halfway through the
song and I say I forgot to pick up
Holden so we finished the song and asked
my teacher if I could go run and pick
him up of course she said yes and I'm
picking up Holden and suddenly there's a
fire alarm and and I and that was a
little scary because we were close to
pickup and I was with the special-needs
kids some of whom were in wheelchairs
some of whom were not were you know a
little physically disabled and we had to
go to the parking lot where the buses
would come mm-hmm and I said oh no what
if this what if this is a real fire and
I have to sit out here and make sure
that nobody gets hit by a bus there were
teachers there of course but you know
it's a public school there may be two
teachers for 10-15 students who won't
need a lot of help sure
so we're out there sitting in the
parking lot and there were students out
there from other classes nearby who
because again this is a fire drill there
were students out there who were with us
and it was the ESC class it was a couple
of the nearby classes and one of the
kids jokingly said as a shooter I said
dude shut the [ __ ] up that's not cool
because how could that ever happen right
and suddenly I see everybody running
back inside and the teacher says get
inside get inside and I said okay it
wasn't a real fire and they want to get
all the kids inside before the buses
come and then we're told to go in a row
and we're told to hide get away from the
window and turn the lights off and I say
okay someone's going on and that
experience was was an interesting one
because I was in the leadership room
with a lot of the leadership students
which is a class that specializes in
leadership yeah and they planned problem
and everything sort of student
government and it was also the
special-needs kids because it was the
nearest room and some of the students
being nonverbal does not mean
can make noise and some of the students
were yelling and wailing fortunately
they had shadows and the special needs
teachers at Douglas are fantastic and we
were able to keep everybody calm but we
didn't know what was going on and we
were there for a couple hours and slowly
more details began to emerge now I
assume you're hearing gunfire and no no
Douglas is a huge school and I wasn't
now mind you I thought I heard gunfire
but when you're told being told your
school was getting shot up and you hear
anything you might think it's gunfire
yeah but I'm sitting there holding my
little brother has no idea what's going
on and and slowly I realize okay there's
a shooting I heard and people were
whispering around the room it was maybe
20 kids in the room people saying 50
people are dead two people are dead one
person is dead the there were
conflicting stories I heard conflicting
stories of who was the shooter was I
heard five different names one of whom
was somebody I knew somebody I knew
would not pick up a weapon to harm a
butterfly mm-hmm because that's hysteria
and that and that's natural and I
understand it then I saw something that
was a terrible exhibit of humanity if
you ask me which was there was a
snapchat video going around that was
that with the caption yo with multiple
O's my school getting shot up and it was
a video of a dead teacher look if you're
gonna film us shooting from inside a
room so you can have evidence to show
the police good on you if you're gonna
film a shooting in a room and say yo my
school getting shot up and send it to
everybody you know that's pretty awful
yeah and when you're sitting there in a
room not knowing what's going on and you
see videos of people you know and love
deceased and then the only video I saw
was of somebody who had I had cared
about for many years he was a mentor in
my life you start to realize that
nothing is ever gonna be the same again
yeah so well let's pause one sec because
that we shouldn't gloss over that part
where the social media component of this
is so important because you guys all
grew up on this and then you grow up
hearing about school shootings all the
time and I could own oh who this kid is
it doesn't matter I'm sure
Imperius a perfectly fine person or he
or she time but it's like you know doing
that it's like it just it almost feels
like oh that's the norm
thing to do like there's a shooting like
snapchat yeah you know several people I
knew we're just treating it like it was
normal I mean not the shooting but the
fact that there was a video and so I
understand how some people might like to
not like but you know understand having
to see that because they need to
understand what's going on but I saw and
I said how could you do that this is
somebody who is deceased and you're
filming them to show to send it to all
your friends and that's a reflection of
the social media era we're in where
everything that's going on you got to
show everyone so for how long were you
actually in that room not knowing if you
were gonna be okay not knowing what was
happening I think it was about two hours
I could look at interviews I did a days
after and have a much better gauge I for
dad yeah but I would call it around two
hours and you know when the SWAT team
broke the door down there was the big
issue that there are students who are
developmentally disabled in here who
might not be able to put their hands up
and fortunately one of the only good
things you'll see from Broward's
handling of the shooting was the SWAT
team was very understanding and was very
quick to help these students which was
good but when that glass broken the
first thing that walked into a room was
a was a rifle how are we supposed to
know that that wasn't you know us taking
our turn but and I everybody was texting
their parents everybody the phone lines
were kind of jammed because everybody in
Parkland was making a call I mean it was
Parkland it was a city with I don't even
know how many people but it was it's a
small town where there's one high school
it's there one high school there's
around one high school you know and we I
mean nobody should be equipped for this
but we weren't yeah have you guys been
taught at all like are they teaching in
high school like what to do if this
actually does happen if a shooter comes
to a school we had the discussion of
having a CodeRed drill we had had long
discussions about dealing with a shooter
but we had never participated in a
CodeRed drill at least not while I was
at school I used to skip school a lot
yeah
tell me a little bit more about the make
up of parkland because you mentioned
something interesting that it's kind of
like a little liberal parkland or some
pretty liberal area it's
you know homogenious when it comes to
being liberal you know there's a lot of
different perspectives but the majority
people in parkland are pretty liberal
and pretty classic liberal and and
that's why you'll see a lot of the
activism to come out of stoma Douglas
was less you know let's let's I don't
know it was very gun control related
yeah so let's we'll get to that in a
little bit because obviously so much has
happened in the spotlight that has been
you know put on you guys and everything
else and several of you have stepped
into it and I think there's there's
probably good parts of that and bad
parts of that I think that's probably
why you're here right now double-edged
sword yeah
okay so it ends now what you know they
tell you all right you can walk out of
this room I mean sure I can't imagine
there's so we branded like we ran with
her hands up we sat outside for a bit I
was able to go on a city bus with my
little brother's class to the Marriott
which is the hotel only hotel in
parkland and so they weren't letting
parents come no two parents were coming
to pick us up at the hotel okay but
there are a lot of different ways
students got out of the school a lot of
different places they went some kids I
know just ran which was understandable
yeah normally when there's a mass
shooting nearby you run and my brother
and I were at the Marriott hotel and our
father picked us up it took us over an
hour to get home because as I'm sure you
can understand the streets were very
jammed you know I mean after the
shooting parkland was a no-man's land
this wasn't Mad Max Anarchy where
everybody was wearing leather spikes but
it was a no-man's land there was it was
as if time and space had been suspended
the rules of physics and matter didn't
really exist it was eerie
it was seven two days at least for me
that was when that period of really
surreal fear would existed that that
nothing felt real and then that camp
news was there there was you know the
most we got was somebody at the
sun-sentinel talking about our
production of Fiddler on the Roof the
did you in that period and I'm sure it's
very hard to even remember it clearly
did you have a real chance to more
to figure out what happened I don't know
you can maybe let me know how close you
were to maybe some of the students
because it seems like and I think this
was part of the problem with the way we
deal with these things is that we go
from the incident to immediately a
special on social media just attacking
each other and destroying each other
then you guys all get thrust into the
spotlight and it's like whoa this would
be hard on on an adult you know
impossibly hard meanwhile you have these
kids who are now out there talking about
these things these kids need to mourn we
need to figure out what's going on with
life and find some reality and decency
so I I think that there's really no
formula for recovering for from a mass
shooting especially when at a school I
mean enough of happened that they're
starting to develop a precedence which
is a horrible thing but there's really
no where to look you can I could have
hidden away I could have locked myself
in my room for weeks and maybe that
would have been the right thing to do I
could have I didn't know what to do and
my way of coping has always been doing
something I had dealt with some tragic
loss this past year and I had there were
some really dark things that happened to
people that I loved and the way I always
handled them was by doing something I
never liked to have a clear head because
well I think it's important to process
your pain and deal with it I also think
that them if I if something like that
happens and I do nothing I'm never gonna
forget myself i I had survivor guilt why
should I have left that day yeah there
were fifteen-year-old girls that were
murdered and I made it out and if I
could have pressed a button to trade my
life for theirs it wouldn't have even
been hmm well maybe I should say goodbye
to people maybe I should think about
this no I would have broken my finger
pressing it to heart so what made me
deserve life when other people who did
nothing wrong if people more innocent
more kind than I am didn't get to make
it out and I realized while I'm alive
and one of my mentors wasn't Scott
beagle one of the nicest guys I've ever
met he's the reason that I'm a snarky
little [ __ ] I developed that from him
mm-hmm he didn't make it out there and
and he's somebody who changed young
people's lives by making them better
and making them more proud of themselves
so what makes me does what has me
deserving of this no I'm not a very
religious or spiritual person so I I
don't I didn't think there was some
great plan that got me out of school but
I think that I had a responsibility I
had a responsibility to do right by the
people we lost and to do what I thought
would make the world a better place
while they can't because there were
marriages that didn't happen there were
people who would have had children and
and that didn't get I don't know it's
it's a horrible thing to think but at
the end of the day lives ended and I
still had mine so I said after the
shooting what I'm gonna do is something
and I was a you know I've been a big
liberal most of my life and ice and I've
always been an advocate for gun control
I was a big debater of other students
after the shooting in Las Vegas where I
said nobody needs these we ran point in
our society where we're advanced enough
that nobody needs an assault weapon to
take care of themselves look at the look
at the way these guns are made we can
defend ourselves handguns and my father
has multiple in the house he's a reserve
police officer he was Miami Shores for a
while I didn't die instantly said the
thing we can do here stop folks like the
shooter in my school from getting these
weapons because this is a 19 year old
who if he had spent five minutes with a
psychologist would have been sent to a
therapist not a gun store yeah okay so
let's before we get specifically too far
down the gun road here which obviously
we're going to touch on okay you guys
are trying to mourn you know you're
having survivor guilt all of these
things I'm sure just in your family and
your brother and everything else just I
can't even imagine then the media
because I think this is we have to hit
media stuff before we get to the gun
cause the media then descends what was
that like I mean I assume everybody and
their brother was trying to reach out to
all you guys they were putting you guys
on TV I mean I probably even that very
day what was that like for you guys or
for you I you know the holes our whole
situation with the media whether it be
anything from CNN to Fox News to Ellen
was a double-edged sword because on the
one on the one hand their bodies that
are warm
and right here on TV and in retrospect I
might have done that differently I'm not
sure on the other hand I couldn't let
this be like Sandy Oak for example I
couldn't let this be people coming in to
film
crying mothers talking about how bad
these guns are and leave I wanted to get
out there and say no okay this how many
of these do we need before we do some of
it I don't I didn't want people to see
parkland as a place where everybody was
crying and everybody was throwing a pity
party I wanted people to see parkland as
a place where a terrible tragedy
happened and the city stood up and said
no we're not gonna be like these other
places we are going to be a catalyst
I mean before before Stoneman Douglas I
would say I would hear the word Sandy
Hook in a room and everybody would get
quiet and it would be weird I couldn't
have that be Stoneman Douglas at this
place that was my school I loved my
school I was a big school spirit fella
it was about to become a statistic it
was about to become that one dark thing
that somebody will make a joke about or
somebody will say something bad about or
really anything I so I got out there and
said no and so many people got out there
and said this cannot be another example
of everybody everybody crying yeah we're
not here to cry we're here to tell you
what we can do to make this a better
world where there are people some
parents advisers whoever that were kind
of guiding you through the media part of
this because there were so many strange
moments where it seemed like look III
said to you right before I don't want to
make this about any specific student
especially and I don't want to throw
anyone out on the bus but when we see
someone like David Hogg who obviously is
very public now you know saying things
that didn't quite seem right or or
talking about laws and all this stuff
like going from just surviving -
suddenly advocacy with almost no space
in between you know it's like the
general idea I think the general idea of
going right to advocacy while it might
not have been our best call to
immediately go to it was these cameras
are only here for so long
mm-hmm and we couldn't have them leave
there's that double absurd exactly yeah
so do we do we wait our respectful time
and then go out and advocate or what
people not care mm-hmm and uh I think I
stand by advocacy I'm not sure I think
on a moral
I might not but on a but generally I
think that well everybody was looking we
had to say let's let's look at what we
really want to look at here yeah
these like give these families their
space where were any of you guys afraid
that you were being looked at as expert
suddenly where as horrific as what
happened to you was it doesn't make you
an expert either in law or in guns or
any of those things like you can very
eloquently as you're doing right now
tell me your story tell me what you
think all of those things but especially
at the beginning I'm sure you know way
more now you don't know everything
nobody knows everything and they were
throwing a bunch of 17 year-olds out
there as if they were experts on all of
these things and I think that also added
to some of the the tumult around
everything well at the time it was
awesome yeah I mean I was an expert I
felt I felt phenomenal I was somebody
that everybody was looking to as if I as
if I knew everything and as I said
before that was what I wanted you know
and and it wasn't a good feeling I'll be
honest with you some things about it
felt good most of it felt like terrible
interesting you just said it's awesome
and it wasn't a good feel it prolly sums
it up I guess yeah it was awesome to me
that I got to the I spent my whole life
watching people talk about laws and
watching people talk about politics and
now I got to say this and my word got to
be respected but every time I went out
there I thought there are people then
and it's it's just it's a it's a moral
qualms mmm I out here at I'm doing this
because I believe in it and I'm doing
this because I don't want the world to
lose people again nobody deserves to be
shot nobody at all nobody who's a good
person deserves to be shot so so I it
was it was difficult for me because on
the one hand it was this amazing feeling
of here's my voice everybody's listening
let me tell you what you all need here
and what everybody need to hear was we
need to pass gun laws and we it's been
enough if people did nothing after
Columbine I would have understood
because that was supposed to be an
anomaly I'm sure you remember that was a
shocker and then Stoneman Douglas
happened and it was more
another not a whoa mm-hmm so so it felt
it it felt great that people were caring
that was that was what I would say it
was the awesome part was that I was
afraid everybody would everybody in the
country would feel helpless and cry and
be done mm-hmm but it was amazing to see
that the country was saying maybe
there's something we can do here maybe
we can make some change and the thing
that was awful was I was I was going
from news hits to to memorial services
yeah so you've had a sort of interesting
evolution about all this and it sort of
leads to where we're gonna end which is
what you're doing now which is pretty
awesome
so all right you're part of the now
you're part of the media machine you
guys are trying to figure out what can
you do
I assume that's sort of how March for
our life started and if I'm not mistaken
it started in your house right started
in my bathroom yeah I was um I was
coming out of the shower isn't putting
on my Ghostbusters PJs it was a Slimer
it was an old-school Ghostbusters yes of
course of course all right
I am we could talk about the new
Ghostbusters maybe after this part how
much hate do you want to get online I am
look I'll tell you this everybody in
that cast is incredibly talented III
didn't like the movie very much but
there's really nobody who was in it that
I think was not is not an incredibly
funny person but anyway I am tired in my
ramen and I got a lot of my friends
together some I called everyone who I
knew was intelligent and well-spoken and
was willing to put their time to grieve
aside to demand action cuz it's you know
I felt like it was in some ways public
service because people are grieving and
we're out here saying we're gonna put
that aside as much as I wanted to cry
every day and mind you I really wanted
to and I did a lot I knew that I had to
put that aside I had to do something so
I got everybody that I knew could do
something to mostly my drama friends
because I knew that they could speak and
we all got together in my house and said
well what do we do with this whole this
whole country people on both sides are
all mourning together how can we get
everybody on both sides together to do
something now mind you that didn't
happen getting people on both sides
didn't really happen yeah that can be a
tough one
it's and it is a tough one and then it
will always be a tough one but it's
something that needs to be done and and
you know from from my home we were
sleeping two hours a night I would go
entire days only eating one protein bar
not even realizing we were so it was
such a tornado that we were all we all
kind of forgot what it was like to be a
normal person so you come up with the
idea for March for our lives now get us
to that day and what was it supposed to
be what were the actual original
intentions beyond let's not forget about
this original intentions we're let's get
gun control past and I'm still a big
let's get going control pass guy mm-hmm
and and that's what we wanted to do we
want to say everybody out here saying we
should do this let's get everyone
together let's let's get a big March
together where people say I want I'm
coming all the way out here I'm standing
out here today to demand this and and
seeing everybody together was amazing I
am you getting up on the stage and
seeing all those people I didn't care
about the being in front of him I mean I
was a drama kid I stood in front of
people and talked for the past five
years but I saw all those people and I
said these people believe in something
mm-hmm
the these people come from different
places these people are all completely
different but they're all together
because they believe in one thing and
that was magical and I don't use the
word magical very often I think it's
cliche but that was magical and it was
it was it was amazing to see but from
the beginning of our advocacy to the
March it was it was a lot of
personalities together and we were able
to make it through the pain we felt
together I mean so often people said
well why are you guys there you know
your school got shot up a month ago your
school got shot up
three weeks ago why are you smiling and
I said well at least from my own
personal perspective the teacher that I
was due you're friends with that I lost
Scott wouldn't want me to cry Scott
would want me to do something Scott
would want me to do what I believed in
he wasn't a very political guy
he will after the shooting he probably
wouldn't a focused on any politics he
would have focused on getting everybody
at Douglas - feel better - laughs -
smile but if I believed in something and
I wanted to advocate for it I knew that
if he were here he'd say we'll go do it
so the time I spent I was sitting at his
memorial and I was crying and my I was
in the dirt I was all snotty I tried to
wipe my face with my dirty hands and I
it was what many would consider the low
point in a movie when the person feels
like they've lost everything and then I
thought about it and if Scott Yoda
behind me as a ghost which he and I used
to talk about actually then I used to
talk about Yoda Inge um if he Oded
behind me and he would say Cameron do
something you must he used to talk to me
and you had a voice a lot and I thought
we were gonna get your Yoda impression
there and it's not gonna happen somebody
else on that one okay
no there were points where Scott was my
teacher in fifth grade and he owed a
voice to me while I was asking him a
genuine question which frustrated me a
lot go home that's for a good time
yeah I could do a three-hour interview
on him but he would have said do
something so so when we were all smiling
together and we were all laughing
together it was because I knew that
somebody that I loved would have wanted
me to and we had each other that's the
thing if I was if I was advocating for
gun control alone it wouldn't have
worked not only because I couldn't have
done it alone I'm not good enough to do
it alone but also because we were each
other's lifeline when I was when when
everything seemed awful and everything
seemed like the world was this dark
terrible place I had my friends around
me to say we got we're here for you
we've got this together and I was you
know some people shoulder and many
people were my shoulder I'm more
emotional than many I'm a theater
student so more people had to help me
that I need to help them yeah and so
beyond the emotional part and getting
everybody together and as you said
you're still a gun control advocate and
all that I sense that part of what
happened around March for our lives was
you saw things getting bizarrely
political or or more than what perhaps
you or you guys wanted is that fair to
say I think what March for our lives
should have it's a political issue I
think the way it should have come off
I think this is what everybody I worked
with believes I know it for a fact is
that we're kids who don't want to get
shot that's what we are at the end of
the day we are kids who are out here
saying we don't want to die and back
then I thought that if you didn't
believe in my gun control beliefs you
didn't care if kids died I learned that
that's not the case but that's a pretty
interesting evolution for someone at 17
to have with him you know five or six
months I spoke to people who disagree
with me I learned that they want the
country to be a better place you know
that we might not agree on how we might
think I might think that their views are
horseshit but every we all agree on
basically 90% of things and I'm sure
there are plenty of political things you
and I will disagree on but at the end of
the day Todd McFarlane is one of the
most gifted spider-man writers we do
agree on that yeah ever do anything with
DC I'm more of a Marvel guy but I had a
pretty good Batman collection for a
while
Nightwing is my favorite superhero yeah
if you're familiar you think I think in
comic books they're very afraid to make
real change and Nightwing actually was
able to make it through that you know if
a Robin became his own superhero
normally that would only be for ten
issues and then he'd go back but
Nightwing actually made that jump I
encourage you all to read three we can
focus on McFarland spider-man from 298
to 335 the idea of venom is brilliant
yeah I saw the trailer for the movie
we'll talk about the off-camera mmm
sounds good
Tom Hardy's gifted so so the way the way
people should have seen us in the way I
failed really in the messaging because I
was so deeply involved there was we just
don't want to get killed and quickly
because of the perfect storm of
everything it became left versus right
and and I don't think anybody my group
wanted that I don't think anybody my
group wants that at all but it's in one
way the media the media's portrayal it's
in one way my personal and ability to
express it correctly and another way my
hair against because I was pretty
arrogant I mean that you know I mean
that from the bottom of my heart I mean
everybody else I worked with the March
for our lives was a kid who wanted to
help the world but I was a cocky little
son of a [ __ ] and that and that
translated a lot because I said I'm
right that's the thing I'm right
everything I say about gun control is
completely right so so what why don't
why aren't you listening to me because
I'm obviously in the right here and
everybody else again was was basically
saying I don't want to die here's how I
think it could work but I said I'm right
politically this is my political
movement listen to my politics that's my
fault
and that's ok I don't blame myself I was
a kid who lost friends and I thought
that this is what we needed and I still
do but the my big error my what's the
what's the word from a tragic hero
that's their flaw her Marsha hubris well
this is your hubris I suppose let's call
it the hubris again I didn't take ap
Lang or AP later I could tell you my
favorite tragic heroes I loved tragic
heroes but my hubris was and again I
could be interpreting this wrong I just
thought I was right I thought that
anybody who didn't agree with me because
I was so right
wanted kids to die 1% of the know I
wouldn't say that my guess is that 3% of
the country doesn't care when kids die
3% just says not my kid or you know it's
not where I am but the rest of the
country doesn't want kids to die and you
know I learned about that that family in
Texas where the mom and the dad both
carry weapons because they want to
protect their family mm-hmm I learned
about the people in everywhere who want
to protect their families I have guns in
my house and while I believe in an
assault weapons ban or at least much
more restrictive laws if you want to
hurt my autistic brother and I have a
gun you're in trouble so when you see
someone like David Hogg and I'm only
mentioning because he's been so vocal
and you know I try to talk about ideas
and not people but when you see someone
like him tweeting all these things but
you know I don't want to get an exact
quote crossed up here but to the in
effect if you don't agree with me you
want dead kids Republicans wanted kids
Marco Rubio doesn't want to save anybody
while all of these things you now
realize that's just not the way to do
that it's not true and it's not it's not
actually effective the reason I
criticize myself and not my friends
because I know David David is a dear
friend of mine I've known him for a
couple years but I've only known really
well since the shooting I in a glass
with him once he was a nice guy
everything David does and I know we're
not talking specifics but I'll just use
David as an example because much like
everybody else in March for our lives
everything David does he does because he
wants the country to be a better place
he and I don't always see perfectly
eye-to-eye on what exactly to do but
every time I see something he tweets
that I don't like and I look I think
about and I say I've spent hours of
David I've known him I know him so
incredibly well because we have this
dark tragic terrible bond that was
really created after the worst case
scenario but when David says something
that I don't agree with he's saying it
because he doesn't want another kid to
die so you know messaging with everybody
in the group has occasionally not really
in sync we agree we disagree on things
sometimes but if I thought that people
in March for our lives like David or
anyone was in this for the wrong reasons
I would be I would instantly call them
out mm-hmm I don't think that's the case
yeah unfortunately the road to hell is
paved with good intentions and I don't
want to merge his intentions hello I
believe I believe you that his
intentions are pure of course I believe
that David's a guy who cares so deeply
about the world around him and will do
whatever it takes to make it a better
place but it's funny that you say the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions because our summer tour where
we went around advocating for more voter
registration and more accessible voting
around the country was called road to
change and there was a counter protester
at one of our events that said more like
the road to hell I said hey that's not
very nice okay so after the March during
the March before the March this thing is
just becoming more and more political as
you said you guys are getting up there
and you want to you know sort of have
your moment but there are certain issues
you don't understand
we're politicians reaching out to you I
know that you know Kyle cashew has
talked to Marco Rubio a couple of times
I mean how deep did this go in terms of
reaching every part of American society
sure we M we reached out to a lot of
people and a lot of people reached out
to us there were a lot of conservatives
that we were speaking to about the issue
I have a couple friends who went to gun
groups to talk about it sat down with
some very big gun advocates in their
areas not really in the country but
notable where they were to talk about
the issue and the I know that the rest
of my group was really interested in
opening up and talking about this again
I was the shady one in March for our
lives
I wanted to stir some [ __ ] you know I
wanted to cause trouble I wanted to make
I wanted to own the Conservatives the
same way a lot of conservatives want to
own the libs I mean that's what it's
about right now people people play games
where they're trying to one-up each
other and you know I just I was trying
to do that I was trying to make
politicians I didn't like look bad as
opposed to say what can we do
yeah when I went up there and I was
where folks or anyone saying you know
maybe ease up on Twitter or like you
know just but just because you're gonna
get no matter what even if everything
you said was factually right and came
from the right place and all that just
the amount of hate you're gonna get
while you're still a young person just
warning so cannot be fun my mom is her
sole existence in the world is to make
everybody in the world happy and love
each other so she said to me be nice and
loving my dad who is a bit of a
political advocate himself agrees with
me on a lot of things and sometimes he
would tell me to ease up sometimes he
would tell me to you know be a little
bit rougher but he also said and and
this is why I think my parenting from my
mom
stepdad dad stepmom was so great was
they said do what you think is right and
don't let people put their hooks in you
and I did I let I let people manipulate
me a bit because I I thought that they
were kindred spirits but you know my
parent I'm lucky enough to have parents
who say believe what you believe if I
might you know my parents are all
liberal but if I came home and said I'm
if I came home with a Trump 2020 hat
which I do not expect to do unless some
drastic change happens in my life yeah
although I know you're not thrilled with
the Democrats at the moment come on
throw the Democrats the moment but I'm
not throw the Democrats at the moment
because they're not being good Democrats
not because they're Democrats mm-hmm but
we all will get to that I am but if I
came home and I told my parents that I
would vote for the opposite of what they
would vote for they would say if you're
doing it because you think it's right
you're gonna do it and I'm very grateful
for that yeah so where do you stand on
gun control generally because I think
what happened was they at the event at
March for our lives there were a lot of
people getting up there and they were
saying things that implied and I think
this is the way a lot of people on the
right took it
it's not about sensible gun control this
is ultimately about taking away all the
guns and that of course is the fear of
most of the people on the right and
there were a couple of the students
there was one young girl I don't
remember who said we're gonna start with
bump stocks but we're coming for all the
guns or something to that effect and
that that feeds right into the people on
the right who go all right well now
we're not gonna talk you got gonna
negotiate who like better laws you guys
are Mao Zedong exactly and then because
of that then the people on the left and
oh you guys go alright see now they
don't want to talk at all so we're not
gonna talk and then you end up sort of
exactly where we're at at the moment
it's and this is if somebody told me
this the other day it's a brilliant
point the left and the right attack each
other's worst arguments mm-hmm and that
does nothing for us but when it comes to
my personal stance on guns there's some
there are some differing opinions
amongst my friends from ours for our
lives but we all we all agree with some
similar things personally I think that
as long as people who are responsible
can carry concealed firearms
particularly handguns in the country in
many situations the country's a safer
place I also think that there is not a
strong vetting process for people to
purchase these firearms and a lot of
people just get guns and a lot of these
people are not the good guy with the gun
because I think the good guy with the
gun argument is just a hasty
generalization I understand it in some
ways because I intend to concealed carry
when I'm an adult because I intend to
have a family and I intend to shoot
anybody who tries to kill my family and
I assume the VAT even that position
right there probably puts you on the
outs with a lot of a lot of your crew
well the outer inception aleem you know
we all respect each others opinions know
somebody in March for our lives and this
is nobody in March for our lives but if
somebody said I want to eliminate all
guns I'd say okay well let's talk about
that mm-hmm so you know my friends
respect me for for what I think and I
respect them some it's difficult it's a
difficult thing to respect people who
disagree with you for those
do you find that you know guys and girls
your age are able to have these
conversations without killing each other
there was a terrible choice of words
without shirt but about being at each
other's throats I think more than adults
are right now is that possible because
that seems to be a through-line with you
that you're friends with a lot of people
of different opinions I think we want to
I think that a lot of people who want to
aren't taking the right steps because
they're saying yes we can we can come to
some common ground if you agree with me
and there's a there's a want out there
and that's something I'm really
interested in because I come from a
generation that I believe puts
principles and morals over money and
political victories and I think that
we've actually got a bright future now
people will call me an insane Bobby
Kennedy [ __ ] per se that we have a
bright future but I think we do I think
we need two distinct conversation I have
a lot of friends who who before seven
months ago I would have thought were
racist sexist bigoted homophobes who
want the country to explode and want to
destroy everybody who isn't exactly like
them and then I learned maybe that's not
the case mm-hmm and I have a lot of
friends who would have thought that I
was some leftist beta [ __ ] shill who
wanted who wanted the Communists to take
everybody's guns and kill him and then
they learn maybe that's not the case I
think our generation really is moving in
a good direction when it comes to smart
conversations I just think we need a bit
of a social revolution they're not a
huge social revolution I love social
revolutions this isn't a a big
revolutions cool it Beatles you don't
think we're late Miz level yet we're not
I guess we're not hearing the people
sing the song of Angry Men yet yeah but
we we need some we need a we need a
movement towards respecting each other
because look before all of this if I
could have gotten rid of the right I
would have and I know people who would
have gone rid of the left if they could
have but it's not gonna happen the
parties might evolve over time I mean
the parties are the parties are flipping
in a lot of ways well think about this
the party of Lincoln is the only party
that currently not the Democrat there
are some Democrats who are like this but
the majority of people who are running
as admitted
white supremacists are part of the party
of Lincoln mm-hmm so a lot of a lot of
switches happen there I mean you've got
some really awful rhetoric out there
from folks like Candace Owens who will
say we'll talk about the Left plantation
look I think identity politics are
dangerous but calling saying that the
real racists are the Democrats is a
hasty generalization I think that I
think there's actually some truth to it
well there's a difference between the
the Liberals and the left mm-hmm
well you're speaking my language
you can't pigeonhole them together
spigen all the right word for that yeah
okay you can't page him whole them
together I'm a liberal but I think that
all men and women are created equal and
need to be respected equally whereas
people farther to the left will say as a
white cisgender heterosexual male I
don't have the right to say any of that
look you a friend of mine Michael
Skolnik who I've worked with before said
something to me that I really
appreciated which was you can't judge
somebody by the hand they're dealt you
judge them by how they elect to play
that hand mm-hmm
people farther to the left will judge me
by the hand I'm dealt I grew up in a
pretty well-off family I had a pretty
easy childhood I could have walked
around my neighborhood without fearing
death which is something that some of my
friends I made in Chicago were not able
to have but they'll say that my opinion
is less valid than anybody's because I
don't deal with the struggles they do I
have an incredible amount of empathy for
people who are not as privileged as I am
I believe the white privilege exists I
don't believe it's as systemic or or
really structural as people say it is I
don't think the government exists to
oppress people but white privilege I
believe exists I believe that there are
certain situations where I will be where
I will be in a better place because I'm
a white cisgender heterosexual male
again it's not this large oppressive
force that people treat it like but it's
something we need to address and that's
that's the real thing I'm talking about
recently which is we can find common
ground on these issues and not try to
push each other away because in my view
in my view white privilege exists
and people will say well no because in
many situations on the SAT
african-american students were given
points and Asian students were were
deducted points and and that proves that
that well I got my cell phone yeah we
don't have to go too far down down that
road because we could have a whole other
conversation on that because I actually
don't agree with you on that but but
that's the point of this yeah that's the
point and and I'm still learning you're
still learning and it's kind of a
beautiful thing I'm 17 I hardly smell
I'm not yet and that's actually the
point of the new podcast I'm putting out
yeah pretty soon it's called Cameron
knows nothing do you watch Game of
Thrones I do look Ygritte told me yeah
and it's true I you know I have my own
personal views on abortion I actually I
watched a video of yours you and I have
this pretty much the same exact view on
the twenty weeks guy mm-hmm but I also
have not taken enough science classes I
also do not have not conversed with
enough women who have had abortions my
opinions mean jack [ __ ] but I'm allowed
to have them you know it's I'm a 17 year
old boy so there's only so much I could
truly say about pro-lifers pro-choice
but I'm allowed to say it yeah and you
know in Cameron knows nothing I'm gonna
tell you guys what I think but it
doesn't mean it's right you know where
do you think that attitude comes from
within you because it seems to me that I
think a lot of what's happening right
now is I see adults that are now afraid
to say what they think and you know they
think that the mob is gonna come after
them which is completely legit they
think it might hurt their job
opportunity or things like that yeah the
mob whichever whichever way it is right
I mean I think what we see boycotts on
both sides and I think a lot of
misguided anger off and but I think most
people need a little bit more of what
you just did there which is I just am
what I am
you know maybe convince me of some other
stuff but I'm trying to learn here I
don't want to hurt anybody you know I
want the government to crackdown on guns
that doesn't mean I want the government
to oppress you I believe that there's a
certain amount of time somebody you
should have access to an abortion and I
think that abortion should be more
accessible just for a certain amount of
time but I don't want to kill babies and
I don't want to oppress women I want the
world to be a better place you want the
world to be a
place I don't know about about you know
anybody up in the booth but they seem
really nice they're pretty good yeah
yeah todd mcfarlane I hand selected
these people exactly Todd McFarlane
wants the world to be a better place
David Hogg wants the world to be a
better place
Jordan Peterson wants the world we all
pretty much all of us do I'm actually
glad you mentioned Jordan Peterson
because you know I'm on tour with him
right now and one of the things that I
find is that first off I meet a ton of
people your age I'd say the bulk of the
people that are coming there are young
people probably probably right around
your age seventeen eighteen into into
they're probably early 30s and it's
male/female gay straight black white the
whole thing but it's very obvious to me
that he's providing some level of
guidance that somehow it seems that your
generation kind of missed now it sounds
like you're your folks are pretty great
in your extended family and all that but
do you sense that there is some missing
piece here that partly I don't know that
there's like some I discussed this last
week with Peter Thiel that there was
some disconnect between the baby boomers
my parents age and that that my guys the
Gen X people we never had our moment or
something and then we've sort of handed
it off to you guys the Millennials and
their dicks I'm genetics
oh I'm Jed Z actually you're Wow whether
those are three or four years older than
I am
all right but that we handed it off to
the to the generation of people who grew
up with with cell phones immediate
access to knowledge response are the
best and worst thing to ever happen to
us yeah if I wanted to get to a hospital
I can get to a hospital much easier with
a cell phone if I want to look up a fact
forgetting the fact that facts are
difficult right now act that facts are
difficult to find who that is if they
you know I can do it but also I before
all of this I was very very obsessed
with my own image not because I thought
I had a good one but because I wanted it
to be good mm-hmm I was posting things
online because I wanted people to think
I had a cool life I mean I did I had a
great life but I wanted people to know
that and it the hyper connectivity of
social media which is a term I stole
from many Ben Platt and reviews were
he's talking about his musical do you
have an Hansen I don't want him to see
this and think I'm stealing the
hyper-connectivity of social media
is um is is a good and bad thing but I
think the problem here and I think that
you know folks like Jordan I'm a big
kind of Jordan I'm a big fan of yours
don't get a big head people people like
you guys one of the things that you
advocate for is is conversation and
people on the right young people on the
right that I know and I'm friends with
they want to own the lips this is all
about proving them wrong and saying like
facts don't care about your feelings I
agree facts by definition don't care
about your feelings but there's also
logic which is kind of the middle
between the two really and that's the
interpretation and the insight and the
fact where you know if we if we only
based everything in facts which a lot of
young people on the right do we're just
talking about the past you can't look at
the future and you can assess facts but
a lot of a lot of young people on the
right want to prove people wrong a lot
of young people on the Left I've seen
want to want to make people want to make
people who disagree with them look worse
it's all about making the other look
worse the right wants to show that the
left is a bunch of commies and left
wants to show that the Wrights bunch of
fascists and that's a waste of time that
is a that is what is harming our country
right now I think Donald Trump's
rhetoric is dangerous and harms our
country but Trump is is the there's a
symptom of something greater like
President Obama said when he made his
return that made all of my liberal
friends think Jesus came back which is
you know Trump Trump is the result of a
country where the people who love Trump
are loving it more than ever and the
people who hate Trump are hating it more
than ever
because we are divided mm-hmm you know
with our rhetoric is is driving these
driving everybody in different
directions that's why you see the rise
of democratic socialism and that's why
you see the rise of more and more people
coming out and saying things that are
stupid because they have the First
Amendment right to do it look if you
said something I don't like I will
defend it with my life I will defend
with my life you're right to say it
but people are mixing being not PC and
being a jerk and and right now we're
driving apart we need to come together
stop attacking each other both sides are
equally as guilty certain sides in
certain situations are obviously guilty
everybody yeah it it's it's it's it's
[ __ ] so do you sense a little more
flexibility on the ability to talk to
people on the right then
on the left because you know that that's
been a sort of big part of what's going
on with me like I get invited to go to
these conservative things in
turning-point USA and I talk about being
gay married and I'm pro-choice and
against the death penalty and all of
these things that are thought of as
leftist things but they invite me we
have a great time I take a zillion
selfies with the kids after and all that
stuff where there doesn't seem to be
that flexibility over there now I don't
want to harp on this because I get your
greater point which is we got to get
past this year but it's where it's what
I am
I do see something on one side
especially with young people that has
become more corroded I would say then on
the others here's what I'll say I say
the left cares too much about people and
the right doesn't care enough and I'll
tell you what I mean because they're
they're equally as wrong here young
people on the right will attack you with
facts and in in either positive or
negative ways and they're open a
conversation very often I believe
because they want to prove you wrong
that's what I've seen from that like
that's not a fact it's an opinion
whereas people on the left want to
accommodate for everybody so much that
if you say anything negative about
anybody that they agree with they jump
to their defense so I'll bring up the
Israel argument which is an argument
that I don't know enough about to form
an opinion I truly do not yeah but if
you are propel that sounds like pretty
much everybody exactly being Pro
Palestine doesn't mean you hate the Jews
necessarily and being pro-israel doesn't
mean that you hate everybody
you made Palestinians but I'll talk to
people on the right and they'll they'll
be happier to talk about it than people
on the left but the second I say that
you know Palestine should have land
which again I don't I don't have a firm
opinion on mm-hmm
they'll say do but you're Jewish how
could you say that I'll say because
people are people and then I'll talk to
people on the left about it and I'll say
there's a lot of concerns of terror and
they'll say don't you dare call
everybody the everybody who's
Palestinian a terrorist and on both
sides you're do so so yes I think the
right is more open a conversation but I
think that more people on the right are
trying to Lou you into a cave where they
could prove you wrong I don't want to be
proven right or wrong right now I want
to discuss because my opinions on things
have changed my opinions really are not
taking a 180 I have all my opinions but
my opinion
opinions is changing hmm that's that's
the most important thing I'd like to
highlight here know if I'm talk is to
think that and we've talked about the
sights to think that if you didn't agree
with me you've hated me now I've learned
a different thing and I'm not and what
what I'm advocating for now is I'm not
asking people to change their
perspectives I'm asking people to stop
having your feet so firmly on the ground
when you're a child because I'm a child
you know I can't rent a car I can't
smoke a cigarette nor do I intend to but
at the end of the day I can't tell you
about I can't tell you with authority
about economics I can't tell you what I
think I haven't taken any Kahn class or
a finance class and we need it you're
already doing better than most experts
on CNN I think people on the left and
the right need just need to realize that
facts are facts feelings are feelings
logic is logic but the more and more we
try to prove each other wrong the less
progress we're gonna make because I have
had the mindset that's we just wanna
stand it I thought the mindset where all
I wanted to do was just own the
Conservatives and I know people have had
the mindset where all they wanted to his
own the libs yeah and by the way I know
you're not just saying this because Kyle
cashew of who I've gotten to know well
who falls off and on the other side of
this in you he's now working with
turning-point and he's you know trying
to strengthen the Second Amendment and
all sorts of other things you guys are
friends and you guys are still able to
talk about these things and we you know
I had originally said maybe we could get
both you guys in here but we thought
this would be a good opportunity just to
let you do your thing and I'll have Kyle
on separately but you guys are despite
your differences you're able to to talk
a lot of things Kyle does I don't like a
lot of almost everything he says I
disagree with there are some things he
says that I think are inappropriate I've
said some inappropriate stuff and and
you know I understand if you don't agree
with me and you want to come out and
speak I I'm proud that I was able to
speak after the shooting and Kyle did
too so I haven't understood deep
understanding of his position so beyond
the podcast and I will give you my word
that I will do the podcast oh please
yeah well you asked me to do it
I'll email was can you do my yeah I'm
more than happy to do it we'll make that
happen what what do you want to do have
you have you really been able to think
about it at this point I know it's sort
of an annoying question to ask a young
person no I mean you know I can't tell
you what college I want to go to I can't
tell you where I want to be in 50 years
but I could tell you that right now I
want to dedicate my time to do and what
I think is the best thing I could do
with my platform because I have a large
platform for all the worst reasons and
with great platform comes great
responsibility
writer man exactly Uncle Ben says that I
believe it was Uncle Ben yeah but when
you say Uncle been on this show people
might be like kindly talking about
Benjamin Parker yeah
and I have a responsibility to do what I
think is right and what I think is right
is advocating for what I believe in but
also making sure that the conversation
is mended and healed because who better
than the people who are about to become
adults to try and make sure that our
next generation of adults knows how to
work together I mean you got Nelson and
Rubio in Florida I'll give you a great
example
Nelson in Rubio have passed some great
bills together because Nelson and Rubio
don't see idea.i to I but they are able
to put their differences aside they get
along and I want more of that
yeah well man I know a lot of people are
worried about the future but I mean it's
clear to me that your future is bright
and if we can hand it over if we can
hand it over to people like you will be
alright because this is this is
everything that I've been trying to do
here I think it's summed up in the way
that you're trying to go forward with
life it's pretty awesome really it's
inspiring
I appreciate that let me ask you
something yes your show I'm gonna we're
gonna swag your flippin emotions you are
in theater all right exactly yeah
so [ __ ] so what what are the qualities
you are looking for in a candidate if
you are going to vote for them over
president Trump at 2020 oh man you're
really putting me on the spot here yeah
this is my show look I've said this
before but it seems to me that
unfortunately the Democratic Socialist
wing of the Democrats has gone really
far left I mean look the word socialist
is in the is in the title now and purged
right I guess they're being honest for
what they are and they're fighting for
what they believe in I happen to
disagree with virtually all of it but
that they're doing that they've
basically purged what I think are the
the remaining liberals as you said
classical liberals before and I think
unfortunately that leaves a lot of us
it's why people watch my show because
I've just been honest about what I see
here that leaves a lot of us suddenly
with allies in places that we didn't
think we were gonna have allies and it's
sort of unfortunate in one way because
you want to always think that you can
sort of stay home and fix things got a
bubble but at the moment I find my
allies have certainly are libertarians
on the right I think I can you know be
allies in a lot of ways with ben shapiro
even though we have differences on the
margins like with abortion and some of
that other stuff but i don't see at the
moment one from when we're taping this
right now i just don't see any hope in
the short term for the democrats my hope
is that this thing implodes that they
get probably have to get crushed in the
midterms which is not looking likely but
that they get crushed in the midterms
and then they have a major course
adjustment where they go we've got to
return to liberalism sure and that is
the answer because I believe liberalism
is the answer I think it's the only
answer but if you know somebody that I
should be paying attention to let me
know because I don't see much you keep
in touch and I'll send you some liberals
yeah one more thing I know we're about
on to yeah what is your favorite musical
and with which musical character do you
identify the most oh man yeah really
going for it I'd rather do favorite
superhero movie you're saying but let's
go to that well I was telling you during
the break that I
I mean I really thought infinity war was
spectacular I think it was just done
right Loki has to be dead though that's
that's the key thing I want but here's
the thing I love Gamora I've she's
amazing I know she's a badass but if
they bring her back which they will
bring back she was killed in the process
of getting the soul stone so they could
say that once they destroy the stones or
what it however it may be right they
could bring her back and I it'll be nice
to see her back because I love her as an
actress I love her chemistry with
everyone yeah but that was a power fire
for me you can't keep killing people and
bringing them back that's why Loki has
to be dead this time which they
basically made it sound like yeah
would I infinity war did a good job with
you no Tony Tony has been the min MCU
for what like 20 movies yeah and he
didn't die Gamora this is her third film
and I felt that yeah I felt that debt I
hate I hate to tell you but she's well I
hate to tell you or whatever she's good
she's gonna be alive but putting that
aside against the musical you know I'm
not a huge musical guy I'm not I know
you don't want to hear that as don't was
a theater guy no not a huge musical I
like Mamma Mia we can we can find some
common Godsey that's what it's about
common ground exact listen man we could
have talked about Marvel movies and all
these other you gave me a lot of adi
pop-culture references before we started
you have to you have to you know break
new ground and that's what I was trying
to do here that's what it's all about I
have no doubt you have a bright future
and you're probably gonna be President
is that where this is all leaving
president of Stoneman Douglas high
schools drama club no because my dear
friend she ran and she's doing a
phenomenal job on that no guys follow
Cameron on Twitter it's Cameron
underscore kaske
[Music]